what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to the first time
that i felt like something weird was
going on in the smith family um before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos um as you guys know i'm
moving to england so each and every one
of you subscribing really helps me with
my move there's been a lot of expenses
so i'm just trying to make as much
quality content as i possibly can
okay let's let's go in my friend group
i'm the only polyamorous person and i
have the least sex
out of all of my friends willow smith
brought the newest debate to red
tabletop it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations on wednesday the
multi-generation dynamic got personal
once again this time with willow's
revelation that she's polyamorous this
has been a journey for you miss willow
how did you make this decision with
polyamory i feel like the main
foundation
is the freedom to be able to create a
relationship style that works for you
okay but where do you think she learned
this like that now knowing what we all
know right where did she learn this
because my parents grew up
with each other
no funny business no sideshifts no
whatever
me and my siblings would never consider
polyamory
because we grew up with that as a model
look at this is the grandma she's not
with this and not just stepping into
monogamy because that's what everyone
around you says is the right thing to
write the 20 year old singer opened up
about her perspective on polyamory
relationships helping her mom and gami
understand her desire to have to have
multiple intimate partners at the same
time so i was like how can i structure
the way that i approach relationships
with that in mind yeah also doing
research into polyamory the main reasons
why monogamous relationships or why
marriage why divorces happen take the
mic away take the mic away
what are you guys doing there's
infidelity yeah let's say you haven't
always been the kind of person that
wanted to have sex all the time but your
partner is right are you going to be the
person to say you know just because i
don't have these needs you can't have
them either or i don't know find someone
that matches you but call me
old-fashioned throughout the series all
three women have maintained an open mind
of topics about sex and mom jada pinkett
smith's reaction here was no different
how did you feel when i told you that i
was polyamorous when you were like hey
this is my get down i was like i totally
get it wanting to set up your life in a
way that you can have what it is that
you want i think anything goes as long
as the intentions are
clear
to everyone most people are practicing
monogamy
because they feel like they have no
other choice right we all know that most
people out here doing unethical
non-monogamy
she's speaking from experience
does this make this a little ironic now
he tried to understand the concept the
matriarch pointed out that many people
still believe in monogamous
relationships there's comfort in that it
provides
two almost like a social order yes
to life and setting boundaries and
commitments most i guess i'm not really
clear on what it offers you could you
imagine being in a group and loving
everyone equally no
this grandma is like who have i raised
like what have i done well then i don't
know what to say that's because of sam's
ideas around love the conversation also
looked to the future and willow admitted
that for her to walk down the aisle one
day there would need to be some
stipulations in place first what are
your feelings and ideas around marriage
as you know it today the history of
marriage really irks me yeah
um just the history of marriage as a
whole and what it has represented over
the years for women in particular i feel
like the only way that i would get
married is let's say me and my partner
or partners want to help people and we
need to put our finances together in
order to
make that vision happen right that's the
only oh my gosh the grandma is so
disappointed oh my gosh the way i could
see myself getting married these
revelatory conversations have become a
trademark of red table talk and jada
told et the secrets behind their intense
this discussions people come and sit
here what's that magic sauce
it just makes people say
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna spill
it well i guess i don't i think it's not
even so much because that's never our
intention yeah exactly
oh my gosh clearly
yikes
what why does my face freeze like this
oh my gosh has it been freezing the
whole video
alright let me know in the comments
because i need
if you guys know how to make a canon
camera like stop freezing because
otherwise i'll have to go back to my old
camera but anyways let me know what you
guys think in the comments don't forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time